Okay, go ahead.
Even if you feel like he's late, because there's nobody to take a decision for you,
in any case we have to do some procedures.
Okay?
There are some things that relate to you, but there are some things that relate to us as a family,
and relate to this family where we are.
Yes.
And you are very good at helping people, starting things like what you already said before.
I am telling you, hey, you need me.
How can I help you?
No, it's too late.
It requires a lot of energy to do, just to overcome such an atomic bomb that you're struggling.
And then you tell me, hey, send me an email.
Why write it down here?
I am the one who has to be speaking.
You said you have to tell me something important.
I have to tell you a lot of things important, but...
I am the one who has to be shut down.
Okay, go on.
I am trying my best to listen, but you're perseverating on this initial reaction that I had.
So, can you actually tell me what the important thing is?
Yes.
I just want to...
For information, you know this pattern that you have to be in the whole night.
And after one a.m. that I...
That you are supposed that I am sleeping, you are going out and buying all these types of food that I understand to eat.
If you want to eat, I rather prefer that we have this wonderful soup, or even bell, or anything
that you can eat, you can eat.
You can eat food.
Food, so you can eat.
Rather than getting the...
Other words.
I could have been feeling with minimal nutrition.
So I will be able to see how at this moment you are still having all this stress.
Okay, what's the next item?
What else?
The next item is that they gave you this present.
Like all we see, prepare some presents for you.
For Taiji and me, she has this envelope.
Your grandfather also has this envelope.
So they are asking me, hey, is it okay to take this to him?
I feel that I cannot do that.
I feel that I need to see you and receive that from you.
And I hope that I am fine.
Okay, what's the next item?
The next item is something more personal.
I would like to notify you that I got the message.
Be sure that I understand what you are trying to tell you.
Be sure.
Which is what?
What if you are that you want to die, that you are a pig, that you are a person that don't necessarily be able to help you.
And should be able to donate to help some other people rather than wasting my time.
Right?
I got it.
Okay.
What else?
The other one is that I know that you insist in your, in your collaborative, your darse is getting, it's getting a lot like, like champs.
You know, from now, the moral is around Trump because he is getting that.
And that is against opening.
Who can deny that he is not an imposter?
Who can not deny that he is a billionaire?
But now all the billionaires are using this.
dream or not. Because his aunt T insists that he has a beautiful, beautiful, beautiful,
beautiful company which is everything in the state and everybody.
Ok, what else?
So, you, but he persists in his vision, you are insisting that you have to go to hell, you have to kill yourself,
there are a lot of things you pick up that narrative.
Step by step, you are dragging yourself and the people around you to that reality, because
there's no reality yet. But you are envisioning your funeral. You are envisioning your kid
and you are looking to your aunt, totally destroyed, you are dis-destroyed, you are acquainted,
totally destroyed. But that's your vision. That's what you see, you visualize, you look for.
No matter what is going there, you are learning.
Ok, what's next?
The next is, the next narrative is the opposite.
You see a guy who is, who is totally fake, insisting to everybody that is in today's room and everybody now is making a difference. Or not?
Ok, what's next? Is that it? Or do you have anything else to say?
No, no, it's different. On the other hand, there are, uh, I think that we are doing a problem.
Thank you, I look like it's both of you, you know, right?
Huh? You don't know.
Oh, sorry.
No, it's like one with, like that. I saw your little time grateful, could you see me and you're 18 minutes.
It's fine, it's fine. It's only 64, it's only 64.
No, I'm sorry.
It's only 64GB, it's nice to have an extra one.
Especially since if you're gonna take videos, one video is like 5GB.
It's completely justifiable.
What's next?
If there is a person, if there is a person, you can understand the language.
I can help you is Kosuke's mom.
Because that's something that you don't know about.
Kosuke-san has his brother.
Do you know that?
No, I mean yes, I did. He has multiple brothers.
No, only one brother.
And do you know what he...
Destiny?
No.
I don't know the details, but I know because he attended our wedding.
And he had a kind of ATSD.
And his life was completely different to Kosuke's.
Because Kosuke-san also has his own limitations.
But he can manage to, you know, to be enjoying his life a lot.
He can manage to be a lot of people.
I have tickets or not.
No.
So you are leaving on 23rd.
I mean, I have to.
I haven't done it yet because they're always putting me on hold.
I always get cut off and it takes so long that I end up not doing it.
What time do you do at 23rd?
8am or something.
I physically can't.
I have to change it.
It's not an option.
Because if I try to go at this flight, I'll be stranded because it's not enough time for me to lay over.
So it's not an option.
I have to change it.
I just haven't done it yet.
So I'll do it either tonight or tomorrow.
And why don't do that?
Because now it's closed.
It's not closed.
Is Asiana?
Yeah.
Asiana has here and Delta.
Asiana has here and Delta have here.
I have to give you information. I will do it for you.
Okay.
I can do it. I just haven't done it because it takes more than like three hours.
I will do it. I have so many things to do, but Ricky...
I said I would do it.
But do it.
Okay.
It's just one week and we were supposed to do that.
Right?
You are going to do it.
You already said, no, I don't want to do it.
I want to pay a new ticket.
Okay.
If you have money, do it.
Because you...
Okay. I'll send you the information.
Yeah. You think that money...
How much do you have from your money?
By this time, I think that it's all and so on.
Yeah.
Right?
Well, look. I wanted to set up a high-saving EELs account.
We tried and then it fell through.
Just things kept happening and then it was all gone before I even knew it.
It's fine.
It's whatever.
The most important message that I just want to know what happened after we came from,
and then I'll be back in the morning. This was Friday night. I don't remember. You were tired, right? And we came here, I also was very tired. I had a conversation by phone. You were waiting here for probably 10 minutes until I arrived. Oh yeah.
I guess I went to bed. You were supposed to explain it because you were very tired. I don't know what happened that night.
I couldn't tell you. I remember. I was like, I can't remember.
You were all night after because next morning, there were happy. You can see. You can see me.
Thank you.
Okay.
And there were probably
people thinking about it too.
Okay.
And I am not complaining about it because
I just want to be
so the same.
I don't understand that
and though I'm not the doctors
I think
we just don't understand
what the brain is.
But
you woke up
all night
Saturday, right?
I'll send you an article that I sent to my mom.
It's very insightful on...
I am talking.
I don't want to say...
Well, you're asking what's going on.
I don't understand.
The article
is writing
the premium.
I want you to read it unless you read it
and there's no point in having this conversation
because you're alluding
to something that I've been thinking about
every single day that I've talked about
hundreds of times, hundreds of thousands of times.
Like the question that you're asking
is something that I've been trying to ask
and answer for myself so many more times
than you have just now
and so that's why I want you to read it
because you're...
it's like...
I mean, you know...
otherwise there's no point in talking about it at all
and I'm just going to end the conversation here right now.
But you think...
Can you summarize that article?
No, not really.
It's a very short article.
Please.
It's all in your work.
Huh?
We don't know what's going on.
We don't know what happens with the brain.
Not even the doctors know.
Treatment is completely ineffective
and euthanasia should be possible for people like me.
Even doctors...
Even some doctors support it.
So...
Basically...
The conclusion of this article is that
you are...
Terminal is...
And that's why they...
It's not a...
There's no conclusions in this article.
It's not such a decisive article.
That's why I want you to read it
because it's nuanced.
You told me to summarize it the way...
Yeah, I am not speaking it.
You don't know that.
Well then why are you like,
"Oh, the conclusion of the article is..."
When there's obviously no conclusion.
But you wouldn't know that
because you haven't read it.
I have...
Or you refuse to read it.
I refuse to read it.